we have a voicemail number you can call
in anytime that number is 2192 David P
this is a really good voicemail John
fetterman the Democratic Senate
candidate in Pennsylvania running
against television Dr Mehmet Oz had a
stroke not too long ago and he has been
recovering from that stroke many right
Wingers are now saying fetterman is not
cognitively there and so this caller
says hey you know Trump brags about
passing that Montreal cognitive
assessment what if fetterman took it
would that satisfy Republicans
uh hi David I'm calling from Australia
just um why doesn't fetterman just take
that Montreal cognitive assessment test
yeah I'd love to see the uh Republicans
tell them that's not very serious his
mate loves the show yeah obviously the
very Republicans who say the Montreal
cognitive assessment proves Trump's a
genius or whatever they said
if fetterman took and passed the
Montreal cognitive assessment as he
certainly would they would not be
satisfied it's a double standard we all
know that the Montreal cognitive
assessment is meant to screen for
relatively serious dementia
and when Donald Trump bragged and then
Sean Hannity bragged about Trump passing
the test
we all knew it didn't really mean
anything
but they claim it's proof that Trump is
brilliant if fetterman passed it they
would come up with a completely
different standard so I think it would
be great if he did it I think it would
be amazing trolling to say I got a
perfect score on the Montreal cognitive
assessment I did as well as Trump did
the Republicans claiming fetterman is
cognitively disabled are not going to be
satisfied on today's bonus show we are
going to talk about the civil lawsuit
filed by the Martha's Vineyard migrants
against Ron DeSantis it is a fascinating
turn of events as a criminal
investigation has also started into
DeSantis we are also going to talk about
the scheme to steal 250 million dollars
from the pandemic child food program
disgusting people truly Joe Biden has
also endorsed a bill to disclose Super
PAC donors that's a good idea but what's
actually in the bill
and lastly the Pacman Finance channel
has launched the first video clip is up
I would love for you to subscribe at
youtube.com
pacmanfinance and we'll tell you about
the plan for that channel and the behind
the scenes very soon on the bonus show
get access to the bonus show by signing
up at joinpakman.com oh the bonus show
where you want to make money there he
also makes money to fund themselves as
bad thank you very much Alex for that
endorsement you can sign up at
joinpakman.com you can use the coupon
code bigdeal919
big deal 919 to get a discount and we
will see you then